let's go next to roland from
vienna now is that vienna austria or i
know that there's cities and towns
called vienna in the united states as
well
that's vienna austria david beautiful
from europe beautiful you know
i if we did not have the virus i would
have been in vienna
in august and i could be talking with
you right now about my favorite
restaurants in vienna but unfortunately
i didn't go because of the virus
well listen mate i have a second
apartment that i was using to
uh for covet it was quite convenient
yeah so give me a ring flop on over
all right i will take it what do you
have a quick king-sized bed or am i
going to have to sleep in like a bunk
separate apartment dude no no i know but
does the apartment have
a a big bed or a small bed
um regular regular people regular size
and uh
queen size is american so it's just a
double i love it i love it
so listen i'm from austria right and i'm
watching this well i was watching it
it's safe harbor day now but
2016 we elected our president yeah
and that got we did a do-over because uh
our right-wingers did exactly what yours
are doing they went
to the courts and on uh
on uh you know on uh what he called like
official errors
they they called the election back and
we had to do a do-over
i'm not familiar with that wrote that's
that's uh that's scary i still don't
think it will be
the presidential election yeah and it
was funny because we ended up saying
uh it was the most successful election
of the right-wing party
and we ended up saying well they they uh
successfully challenged it
yeah they successfully challenged their
most successful election and then lost
so we pulled together you know
so is your is your message a message of
warning that it could happen here as
well
a lot of people are saying it's
impossible i think it is now after safe
harbor day yeah
but it has happened in western civilized
countries
and i think this will be important this
will be the end this will be the mo
going forward for a lot of right-wing uh
crazy parties they will just try to
steal elections they've lost
yes yes yes yes i don't disagree i have
a quick question yes
do you think biden is going to do the
full term everyone's talking about trump
2024 he's going to be a
very old man i don't even see biden
doing the full term
in fact i would be interested what do
you think the chances are that biden
hands over
after the 2022 midterm elections to
kamala
to allow her to be in the driving seat
for her first election
i mean again that would be such a rare
event in presidential history that me
saying
i think it's this percent or that
percent would would essentially be
meaningless
um i i i am aware of the actuarial
tables and life expectancy
and i have a sort of realistic
understanding of the fact that
joe biden is 78 and donald trump uh
would would be that age or even older if
he were to run in 24 but i i wouldn't be
able to make any specific prediction but
i do expect joe biden to serve a full
term
great listen dave uh long time listener
you really uh
i like your style neutral but still left
leaning
and you know i think everyone knows
because if you look at sam cedar's
uh youtube account numbers he's not even
at the one million market yet
that's a low blow sorry that's a low
blow that's a low blow that's aggressive
roland
thank you well i'll i'll leave you i'll
leave you with this low blow you know
i also don't think that you need your
own your own only fans channel
okay i think you can show your zook off
on your
tremendous bonus show that'll be
sufficient for us all right roland from
vienna and
roland are you pro or anti-salzburg
austria is it good there is it nice
so my parents are there it's uh you know
very hoity-toity
oh um it's nice it's nice the rural
areas are nice yeah again
it's very it's very condensed us
viennese we say
salzburg in vienna has the same amount
of tourists but salzburg is 10
10 times as small so right right and can
you can you get it can you get a good
cappuccino in salzburg
oh oh listen david i'm sorry to quote
you
[ __ ] your cappuccino because it's
melange in austria oh is that what it's
called there
melange a viennese melange yeah vienna
is the home of coffee house culture
well listen i'm gonna have to go there
deep when you're here please
thank you all right roland from vienna
and producer pat we will have to we will
have to bleep the f-bomb that was very
very strongly dropped there
uh but he felt very strongly about it
and and so i sort of um
i sort of understand i guess i would say